you're in a relationship and the
relationship is not great but it's not
terrible they're not abusive they're
fine they support you and stuff but it
really doesn't fire you up and you're
not that in love with them or you live
in an apartment and it's been expensive
and it's in a dodgy area of town and
there's a bit of mold on the ceiling but
the landlord's quite nice and you know
it's convenient it's not far from your
work all of these situations for these
people would actually be better off if
they were worse because if the apartment
was unlivable it would force them to
look for someone new and this is how
people get stuck in region beta which is
this Chasm of comfortable complacency in
the middle not sufficiently bad to make
you change it but it's not good enough
for you to say oh this is good this is
actually great it's just acceptable and
that's how people get comfortably numb
and the problem is that the world at the
moment is so convenient you can ubereats
a Michelin star meal to the apartment
that you Amazon Prime the brand new
couch to while you Netflix a
award-winning series on your TV and that
means that you can sedate yourself out
of a lot of the big problems that you're
facing in life in just anesthetize any
of the concerns that you've got